who you in this vastness hey everybody
it's Charlie we got a brand new
comic-con venom preview to break down we
got our first look at the Green Goblin
in more details on what's going on with
their connection to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the future of the venom
movies a la carnage they've been a lot
of rumors thankfully they address those
in a new interview so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos make sure you
enable alerts so you don't miss any of
the Comic Con videos next week there's a
new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
the video - first big thing we got a
shiny new preview of Venom's head with
the smile that goes all the way back up
to the top of his head that this is
right out of the comics we are way past
Topher Grace venom at this point
if you've seen ant-man and the wasp then
you understand how good they're getting
with motion capture CG swapping actors
faces so what you probably saw in a lot
of the behind the scenes videos I posted
earlier this year is you would have Tom
Hardy running around on set with motion
capture dots on them and they would just
do this in post-production it's very
similar to what they do with Robert
Downey jr. Iron Man fantastic actor Tom
Hardy fantastic actor technology is just
in a place now where they can allow
those actors to just do their craft to
the best of their abilities and worry
about like big heavy costumes stuff
later in post-production though Tom
Hardy's fantastic I don't think there
were any doubts about his performance I
think there were just questions about
how they were gonna change Venom's
backstory they did explain some of that
during this new interview so they talk
about Eddie Brock in San Francisco is a
down and out on his luck reporter just
like he is in the comics he's recovering
from a recent scandal they don't say
what the scandal is but he's in disgrace
and looking for a big break that comes
through his girlfriend who works for the
Life Foundation who is Riz Ahmed
character you see him strapped into this
chair here this seems like after they
find that he has the symbiote but before
he learns to control it and before that
we are venom moment so timeline of the
movie Eddie Brock down and out on his
luck finds out about what's going on at
the Life Foundation thinks are really
shady goes to investigate them remember
he's kind of shady himself morally great
so he's not about breaking into places
to get leads on stories he finds out
what's going on with the symbiotes but
doesn't understand it so just gets
freaked out takes off the symbiote binds
to him and you get that first scene in
his apartment where he still has no idea
what's going on he wakes up and probably
has vague memories of what he did the
night before then the light foundation
men come chase him down in the symbiote
starts automatically protecting him that
starts their relationship and they spend
like the next little bit of the movie
going back and forth like the movie is
about them achieving symbiosis and
becoming a single organism together we
are venom so it seems like that's the
big payoff at the end and it does sound
like Tom Hardy did the voice for venom
and Eddie Brock he actually liked when
they were doing this interview
demonstrated both of them so he goes
really deep when he does the venom voice
one of the other cool teases Tom Hardy
dropped as he said there's a bite
heads issue which is not what you would
expect from say Captain America taking
down a crook so this is Tom Hardy
basically saying that the Venom symbiote
early on when they're still sort of
bargaining with each other trying to
figure everything out
starts literally biting people's heads
off so even if this we are venom is
happening later in the film he might be
one of the criminals that venom bites
the head right off of so that would
definitely earn you a hard-r rating
which was the pitch for this movie a
long time ago but I think that we were
all kind of wondering what that would
actually translate to on screen and when
he was talking about the difference
between his version of venom and his
Eddie Brock character he referred to ren
and stimpy so tom hardy just outed
himself as a big ren and stimpy fan
which i think is pretty awesome the
interesting thing too is the way the
article refers to its relation to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the Sony
sharing arrangement with the spider-man
Peter Parker character so that's Tom
Hollands deal like when you refer to the
sharing arrangement that's just for Tom
Hollands spider-man character
it sounds like Kevin Feige and Marvel
don't really want to have anything to do
with venom right now I think I mentioned
that in the last venom video that I
posted like they're just taking a
wait-and-see approach they're not gonna
use the eddie brock venom character in
any Marvel Cinematic Universe movies
anytime soon so I think that backdoor
confirms that no symbiote during
Avengers 4 or spider-man far from home
for now with the article is saying this
isn't Marvel or Sony saying this so take
it with a grain of salt that the venom
movie is not part of that Sony Marvel
sharing arrangement in whatever they do
with Tom Holland in the venom movie if
he does appear it will be separate from
Marvel sharing arrangement so yes
technically Sony has the right to do
whatever they want to with Tom Horne but
I think if they haven't already there's
probably been some meetings more
recently to create an addendum for this
spider verse that Sony is creating in
how much or how little they're allowed
to use Tom Holland in that Marvel and
Kevin Feige have no control over what
Sony does with venom the Morbius movie
that Jared Leto is doing
that's right Jared Leto is going to be
Morbius for Sony in their spider-verse
but they haven't said a whole lot about
that movie while at the same time also
still being the Joker in the DC EU and
if it wasn't clear the Morbius movie
will be
connected in the same sort of universe
with the venom movie but that will not
be directly connected to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but they are free to
use those Sony characters and future
movies if they want it sounds like now
based on what this interview is saying
is that it's more like James Bond
continuity we're like yeah it's same
characters same universe but the
filmmakers in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe don't want to deal with what
Sony's gonna do with their movies but
they might want to use those characters
later so if you do see Eddie Brock venom
pop up in the MCU in like three or six
years when they get past that third
spider-man movie just assume that enough
time will have passed that unless the
venom franchise just blows up big time
they'll just be free to do whatever they
want to with Eddie Brock's backstory
when he shows up for the first time so
if Tom Holland is attached to this venom
movie if there's a spider-man cameo it's
a lot easier for them to do that if he
has his mask on usually that's the kind
of stuff that gets ironed out in test
screenings like they'll change the
costume a little bit or they'll
reference spider-man and some other way
but if you look at all the white lines
on Venom's costume here it does kind of
look like he's gonna have the spider
symbol by the end of the movie but the
Comic Con trailer is gonna be posting
Friday night of course I'll do a video
for it we'll get a much better look at
Tom Hardy in the costume I'm sure it'll
be badass I'm not expecting to see any
teases for carnage till the actual movie
drops itself I think they're gonna try
and keep that under the vest but I think
we definitely feel like Woody Harrelson
is playing the Cletus Kasady character
and he'll be carnage in the next venom
movie or wherever these characters pop
up next
during that panel Sony is also probably
gonna drop a new trailer for spider-man
into the spider-verse we got our first
look at the Green Goblin so he looks a
little bit more like ultimate Green
Goblin but they're going with a more
Ultimate Universe because it's Miles
Morales so I think even if you haven't
read a lot of those comics you have a
vague idea of what it's going to look
like but a really cool thing that they
just confirmed is that Nicolas Cage is
actually going to be playing spider-man
noir and they're going to be unveiling
other versions of spider-man that will
appear during the movie - Hailee
Steinfeld is playing spider-gwen
Liev Schreiber is playing the kingpin
and they have not revealed
who's playing Norman Osborn Green Goblin
so we'll probably find out about that at
Comic Con but that's all happening
Friday night saturday is
to be Warner Brothers panel so that's
the Aquaman trailer ashes am teaser and
then maybe some behind-the-scenes teaser
for Wonder Woman too then obviously all
the TV stuff that's happening I've
already got a pretty good idea of what
my comic-con video schedule is gonna be
I'll be sure to give everybody video
updates on Monday or Tuesday about what
that's going to be I'm still waiting for
them to announce a couple panels so
everybody freaked out it's gonna be a
rainy trailer footage really soon and
even though Marvel Studios isn't doing
any Hall H panels they also might drop
some news bombs about Captain Marvel
Avengers 4 and spider-man far from home
even though I'm not expecting Tom
Holland to come to the Sony panel on
Friday he could show up but I'm not
expecting it leave all your requests in
the comments below and all you have to
do to enter that blu-ray giveaway is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so click here to learn
about Nick Fury crossing over with
spider-man far from home and click here
for that Shazam teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]